hi i'm kerry mulligan and i'm gonna be
taking some questions from fandango on
my new film promising young woman
uh compelling troubling
hilarious i'm most excited for people to
see
bo burnham dancing erotically with
a tin of span i think
i frightened sam richardson the most no
that's not true i think i frightened
chris mintz platz the most
but he sort of frightened me a little
bit too
i think toxic has to be my favorite
britney spears song
from now and forever i mean the
soundtrack also has some
some real gems um namely juice newton
which comes in right at the end which
genuinely might be one of my favorite
songs
i think cassie is sort of an
amalgamation of a million stories
um and a million people's reactions and
stories that we've all kind of grown up
with
i hope audiences feel the way that i did
when i read it in that i just haven't i
haven't come across a film like this
um i think it's it's totally unique
hopefully it will continue a much needed
conversation around consent
and the way that our culture has kind of
normalized a lot of the behavior that
you see in the film
um and how we can hopefully change
the most promising thing about 2021 has
got to be
you know a vaccine of some description
whichever one
you can get handsome uh the most
promising thing about 2021 is yeah the
the hope of
life returning to normality um or some
semblance of normality
be sure to check out promising young
woman out now